9h40 norway est enfin prêt à entrer dans
les cluses une exclusion de 350 mètres
pour le plus long paquebot 315 m bien
des manoeuvres délicates pour les
abeilles qui nous ont cessé de les
multiplier à lapproche même de les
cluses
on les a vus peu avant observé les
gérard est ensuite elles ont repris et à
l'avant toujours la bei provence qui
elle tire le nord
mais revenons à hier soir hier soir où
les curieux cet art depuis longtemps que
ces derniers jours a même heure on sait
que les remorqueurs hollandais sont en
vue sur la rade
mais ils ne gagneront le port que plus
tard sécurité oblige
une arrivée très discrète seul est
perceptible le roulement des machines
les remorqueurs se succèdent à cinq
minutes d'intervalle l'abeille nederland
tout d'abord bretagne et y en a quatre
ils vont ceux disposés autour de du
norway et est environ minuit lorsque
celui ci s'apprête à désamarrée en
termes du métier le décalage qui va
débuter après l'opération de des
doublages qui consiste à retirer les
amarres 35 à nara retirer les la mineur
vous voyez spécialisés de ce travail
s'exécute mais en raison d' incertitudes
météorologiques l'opération est ralentie
entre temps des militants cégétistes
manifeste vers 5h45 tout de même le
commandant du norway donnera l'ordre
d'appareils l'évacuation des militants
se fait sans heurts et bon vent jusqu'à
lécluse les plus que franchi le norway
il n'y aura plus de problème pour
traverser les autres bassins
à autun du sémaphore norway va saluer le
trois coups de sirène il ne lui sera pas
répondu ou si peu quelques bras
s'agitent un fichu bleus que l'on
balance quelques instants la seule note
colorée du départ la marseillaise en
réponse tombera au bout de la jetée
alors que les slogans qui suivront
n'auront pas de suite
ultime sursaut organisée par les
militants cégétistes et communistes ce
qui domine l'impression d'un silence
profonds et lourds tandis que ça pèse
dans une heure d'école france s'impose
au regard
il n'existe plus que huit tous se tait
pour quelques instants seulement
bientôt le public re devient photographe
et bavard pas tout le public qui
lèverait des visages crispés des
expressions figées des pleurs dit cela
parfois il n'y a pas eu que des curieux
pour l'adieu aux france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]